video and i think it's cnn or msnbc and
they're going on and on about how trump
has now made lying uh the currency of
the day and and no one tells the truth
anymore facts don't matter and they're
talking about the kinds of lying that
trump does where he talks about the
crowd size and how much money he has and
stuff like that the lies of the left are
huge lies and they damage the country
the lie that racism remains a major
problem in america it's a lie the lie
that women make 77 cents on the dollar
for doing the same thing that men do it
it's a lie the lie that rich get rich
the poor get poorer these are lies and
these are big lies that drive the left
and drive votes these are the kinds of
things that matter so when you sit
across from a guy you ever notice that
all of those things that they're lying
about in in
make you scared
incite fear
and anxiety and like stress
that's one thing that
i noticed with this last election
a lot of it was fear-based and i'm like
if people actually researched and just
bumped the media bumps social
news outlets and really like looked for
themselves
i think it would have went a little bit
differently but
it was a lot of fear base if you like
this one this is what the world is going
to be like if you like this one this is
what the world is going to be like
instead of just going off of
facts yeah
and it's
it's interesting too because
i don't know the media just paints
the the right is so bad
like i don't know i don't know why the
media like hates the right but i just
feel like they have money in places that
they don't want the conservatives to
like touch
you know what i mean
like i don't know like they don't want
their money taken out of like schools or
out of like special interest groups and
that sort of stuff like i think there
just has to be some connection between
the media and the left because it is so
left-leaning like even entertainment
yeah like you were saying um the other
day how that one show
was very like politically pushed yeah
like once you see it you can't see it
you'll see all these political like
like yeah it it i think it's to
brainwash the next generation of voters
from a young age
they're trying to get what i said if you
get them at a young age you got them
they're trying to get trans
like they're trying to teach trans stuff
in schools
that's politic like politicizing kids
yeah once you see it you cannot see it
the first time we did it when i really
still felt i was part of the left i was
trying to reform the left realistically
i'm not part of the left anymore you
know and again the left right thing as
we talk about all the time doesn't even
have that much meaning anymore it's
really about authoritarians libertarians
and all that um
but for all the years that you've been
doing this staking out conservative
positions for how many years publicly 25
25 years
was there a more sensible left at the
time was there a guy you could sit
across from that you disagreed with
intellectually but felt that it was it
was forthright it was honest you just
disagreed with the methodology and the
results sure there were lots of people
that i felt that way with and william
buckley had a very good friend uh john
kenneth galbraith who was a left-wing
economist they disagreed about
everything they were good friends uh
believe it or not antoine scalia's best
friend on the supreme court is ruth
bader ginsburg what it requires is
somebody to recognize that if i have a
position that's different from yours it
doesn't mean that i'm a bad guy it
doesn't mean that i'm evil it means that
i see the world differently it takes a
certain kind of maturity to do that say
it louder for the people in the back sir
oh that that right there
it
i feel like if more people understood
that
a lot of things would not be a problem
if people just understood
that
you're not going to think like me and
i'm not going to think like you but i'm
open to hear what you have to say to see
to try to understand how you see the
world i may not agree with you in the
end
but
i'm open to it and so many people are
not
open to having conversations like that
to where they disagree it's like how how
can you see the world like that this is
actually what's happening it's like
but you cannot
everybody sees the world differently
everybody and to dismiss someone's
literally eye gates that they experience
the world through it's just the missing
dismissing them in general
and i feel like
if more people were more open to that
and understood
that
i think that's why the audience likes
you is you're very open
it's rare no it's rare now yes yes it is
very rare nowadays because there's some
things that
we have talked about i'm like
yeah okay like i hear you and i'm like
okay like i understand how she could see
it like that i still think the way that
i think but it's like i'm not like oh my
gosh pearl how could you ever think that
you know i've had people stop being
friends with me over this channel i had
my best friend of like
20 years
stop telling me she couldn't be my
friend anymore
wow because of the stuff i post and i'm
like okay so you're telling me it's
crazy about the left i bet you if i
started an only fans she'd be cool with
that content i bet she would still be my
friend still support me
but i post conservative values
and i'm the bad guy yeah
it doesn't make sense it's making me
it's this girl oh my gosh um
so it was just funny because
like because her whole argument was like
well my kids that she doesn't even have
kids she's like my future kids
are gonna see this and i'm just like
so you want to stop being friends with
me now for kids that you don't have norm
do you want to cross that bridge when we
get there yeah exactly so essentially
she didn't really want to be your friend
period because if it's something like
that that stops you from being your
friend oh
i'm a big ball of fun too she's missing
out she is missing out she could have
flew out to london and been on your show
a big sorry man you're missing out
a big ball of fun we have good times
over here unfortunately we've gotten to
the place now where if you don't believe
that racism is a major problem in
america uh if you're black you're a
sellout if you're white you're a racist
if you say something negative about the
black panther which i just did
i got
some guy told me that well it's because
it's a black person and a black director
and a black hero and therefore you don't
like it
i mean the star is guy named chadwick
boseman and i was fortunate enough to be
invited to see the premiere of 42 he was
brilliant i saw the movie three or four
times i like him so much i saw him in uh
a movie about uh thurgood marshall which
was a very good movie probably not
commercially uh
successful but it was a very good movie
and i saw him play in the movie with uh
we played james brown he was very good
the movie wasn't that good but he was
good yeah so he's an intriguing actor
again i don't go to see a movie to to
not be happy to waste my time yeah and
you're a comic book guy i mean the
reason we were talking about comic books
is because i've got a whole bunch in the
green room here what he just said about
um
the movies and the movies that chadwick
boseman did
a lot of them a few of them that he said
they just didn't do good in the um
in the box office or in
wherever they were showing
and
that's something that goes into play
what we're talking about in the oscars
like there's a lot of
great black actors that
do these
movies that just
don't turn out great and they just
don't perform well at the other as these
other ones and so
i wonder if they're having those
conversational how how do we do
how do we get to a point where we're
able to
produce these great films produce
all of this great work
and then
get
produce it to where it's at a standard
where it can hang with the big dogs
and then
it's essentially
how am i trying to say this
so
rewind i wonder if they're having those
conversations so okay where can what do
we need to do to be able to be in the
mix with all these other
great movies that are white led to be
able to be in the mix with them and be
at the standard that they are i don't
know if they're having those
conversations because a lot of a lot of
black movies
you
you really
nowadays you see them but some of them
are very under the radar undercover and
if we don't if they're not pushed by
mainstream we don't know about them and
i wonder if that's the type of
conversation they're having to be able
to be recognized at the officers or just
like the oscars are too white
yeah which one do you think could be
more effective
the not the oscars are too white but the
how do
what what is it that they're doing
what is the formula not the formula but
like how
let's let's look at it a little bit or
let's just produce
better movies or produce great films to
where if we do not get recognized
then we can say oh why don't we get
recognized here when looking across the
board we are exactly the same with the
winning cop with the winning competition
why didn't we get recognized as well you
know what's interesting so i think about
the jordan peterson interview
where jordan peterson was arguing with
that feminist right and the feminist was
the one complaining about the problem
and jordan peterson was the one actually
fixing it because he was helping women
get better wages right and it's almost
like
are you happy about that and it's almost
like the people that are the loudest do
nothing that's what you're gonna you're
gonna once you see this you can't unsee
it like
i swear to god the the friends i have
that were the loudest about like black
lives matter when like everything was
going on they don't even interact with
black people ever
and like they they don't do anything in
their day-to-day like but they'll post
on social media and complain but i i
know them you're not donating to any
cause
you're not you're not doing anything
and they're the same ones that'll text
me and be like why didn't you post
anything daddy you're conservative
and and but i'm like
[ __ ] you need to like one one
you don't even have five dollars to your
name i know you're not doing [ __ ] for
this
like maybe get off your phone
go get an extra job save a little money
and then donate it donate something but
it's like a lot of times when you ask
people or you'll be like why don't you
give up your position
or like like when they're
they actually have to do something it's
like nothing yep
that's and once you see this you can't
you can't see it
you were immediately going on about all
this stuff you loved so it's not like
you're walking into that thing to hate
it right and so the criticism is just
bizarre i mean
what do you think i am what do you think
i do i get in the morning hate myself
gouge my eyeballs out try to claw my
skin color off i mean that's just
and and and dave i feel sorry for people
like that people have often asked me
does it make you mad it doesn't i feel
sorry for you if you are so trained so
indoctrinated to be that's rabid against
somebody who just has a different point
of view there's a problem with you not
with me
you did it
you decided to get in the game
i had people they're really up in this
production yeah i see the i see the come
up dave
i see the come up
there's a gazillion people out there
like fix california nobody ever no good
people decent people ever want to get in
what finally dragged you to do it so
many people like you wait larry elder's
running for office
where i didn't even know he said why
don't you do this dennis prager first
asked me and i said
dennis hell no he said why i said
california is practically ungovernable
we have two-thirds super majority in the
senate two-thirds super majority in the
assembly plus a left-wing governor the
the environmentalists run this state the
teachers union dominate this state it's
almost ungovernable hell is he trying to
be
like recently because no this sounds
recent cause this is this clip is from
2021. is he trying to oh he isn't
running for governor but he may run for
president
oh oh
okay you
would you vote for him
when did he say he was shot i mean 2022
is 2022 the next election
for president oh sorry sorry no like has
it been four years already i met like
that's when the article came out no
larry elder isn't running for california
government but he may win for president
um
larry
elder won more votes than any other
candidate hoping to take gavin newsom's
job in california's recall election in
2021
okay so i guess he did run but he will
not be running for california governor
in 2022 i'm a realist i know that in
california democrats and independents
who typically vote democrats outnumber
republicans almost three to one so i'm
not sure a rematch in short term would
make a whole lot of sense
um yeah but basically he's thinking
about running for the next president do
you vote for him
personally i would
i would want to see what else he stood
for you'd think about it yeah i would
think about it but i know that
a lot of people wouldn't yeah
based off of how
he thinks and
that sucks because
some of the ways that i've heard some of
the things that i've heard him said
would be so beneficial
for the black community
but if they're not open to
a progression in that way
he would be called anything and
everything
in the book of names
by the community
because they because
it's different
hmm that's interesting if i see you on
the if i see you on the ballot sir
they ponder on it
oh no then it's good okay i understand
and then i got approached by a guy named
pastor jack hibbs also a very good
friend of mine
and he made the same argument dennis did
and then a friend of mine named lionel
chapman chetwin a longtime filmmaker
also made the same argument and then
just normal people that i know in my
life my gardener my the guy that drives
me from time to time the guy that opens
the door when i come into my uh to my
office buildings from time to time
people that were that i work with and
nobody said well larry geez you have a
great life oh my goodness you're
starting to make money now and and
you've got a long time relationship with
your girlfriend nina why jeopardize all
that and nobody's lived a perfect life
and i'm sure you haven't too why expose
and no one said that i kept waiting for
somebody i respect to say that
my mother and my father are no longer
with us uh my brother just died he was
my best friend he died september 13 2019
two weeks before his 70th birthday and i
know what he would have said he would
have said go for it that's just how he
is
my mom would have said go for it my dad
would have been more reluctant about my
own privacy in my own career but my
mother would have said go for it she's
been more political than i am so i
couldn't i ran out of reasons not to do
it and the more i watched gavin newsom
the more he ticked me off the way he was
sitting at that restaurant called the
french laundry
dave i never heard that restaurant until
he was there i thought it was probably
the most elite restaurant in california
it's not i thought it's most elite
restaurant in america it's not it's one
of the most elite restaurants in the
world oh yeah an area is sitting there
incurring a tab some people say it's 12
grand i heard it as high as 30 grand
with the very medical professionals
and the lobbyists that drafted the
mandates that they were violating by not
wearing masks and by not socially
distancing at the height of lockdown
this wasn't two weeks and his two kids
were enjoying in-person private
education and he exempted his own winery
from the from the
mandates when those pictures came out in
california
oh people were pissed because he we were
all forced to wear masks everywhere and
restaurants like certain restaurants
couldn't have a certain capacity because
of the mass
and people were pissed they said
gavin newsom is at a restaurant no mass
people around him no mess he's just
chilling there it's like how can he do
that they were trying to get him out of
there yeah well it's crazy because this
is another thing you can't unsee is they
they make laws for other people that
they don't even follow
that's why like people should not have
to get to make laws like that they don't
follow themselves how messed up is that
yeah you should have some repercussions
the law is for you too if you don't want
to follow it don't make the law so the
question is why
are they pushing these laws if they
don't believe it themselves
it's about control they want to know
that they can control people um
next log avenue so makes i ain't
following it
unless it's something that's very bad
and i should follow it
and this kind of arrogant smug entitled
attitude really started taking me off
and then you add to that the crime and
the homelessness and the hellacious cost
of living in california
see with that i would want to hear
his stand on all that stuff
um
if he was running for governor even if
he was running for president i would
want to hear his stand on that
larry you're scared blown me away once
or twice over the years but are you
telling me that the conservatives are
not racist are you are you telling me
that the conservatives don't hate gay
people and that the conservatives
generally want to live and let live is
that is that what you're dropping that's
right that's what i'm saying most people
want people to realize the potential why
would it be in anybody's best interest
for a group of people to be to perceive
them as racist how is that making things
better don't you want everybody to be
law abiding
drug abstaining tax paying people
doesn't that make everything good
whenever i ask people about systemic
racism and i always say can you can you
name names what do you get david duke
after that after that the list is pretty
short isn't it give me the name who in
congress on the republican side is
systemically racist give me the name
give me the name and sometimes they say
trump are you kidding me
best economy ever under trump uh he
pardoned jack johnson the first black
heavyweight champion that obama didn't
do despite the fact that ken burns the
lefty uh documentarian came to obama and
said please pardon this guy didn't do it
sylvester stallone please pardon the guy
didn't do it uh trump does it he also uh
commuted the sentence of a woman named
alice johnson
very long uh non-violent drug offense uh
he put permanent funding of historically
black colleges on for ten-year footing
no one that had done that before
expanded opportunity zones dropping some
of the rules and regulations in
distressed areas so that you you invite
more business if he is a racist he needs
to go back to racism school when you
were watching the state of the union and
he mentioned lois black unemployment of
all time and then to watch the
congressional black caucus
right like to me that was everything
that you've preached about in your 40
years doing this how many years you've
been on here
with
with
it's hard because
i'm gonna say it's hard a lot because
it's hard people so don't come in the
comments
these aren't easy topics yeah no and
it's
it's okay to not be sure yeah you know
but i've
i heard
i heard um that he i can't remember
exactly what he did in
the
black community in the south but trump
did but i know that he
did something positively
and what just the things he was naming
off
i heard some of those but it's
in the back of my mind i'm like what was
he doing it for was he doing it for his
own gain but it shouldn't be like that
it should be like if you see
he
he essentially did
things
for
more things for
the black community
than
any other president before him
and
it's
it sucks that
stuff like that
isn't
shown
to like show like hey there is yes he
may say off the wall stuff yes he may
have done this that and the third with
whomever
and is not right
but
let that stuff be like legal stuff that
he has to deal with on his own that's
not affecting
that's not affecting america that's that
let's focus on like the actual things
that he's doing
and
whatever he says out of his butt he can
say it but is his
is the tactics not tactics but is the
things he's doing positively affecting
whatever community is in or is it
negatively affecting
whatever it's set for do you think
intentions matter
what do you mean by that so like when i
look at someone
i don't really care what a president's
intentions are i care about what he did
and how it affected people and what the
results were
and i think a lot of times we'll focus
on like people's hidden intentions but
at the end of the day you're never going
to know why someone did something
you will literally never know and if
trump was so racist why was he so
accepted in pulp pop culture by like
like he was on tv for so long and nobody
had an issue with him yeah he was on
like he was in that
what's that movie the the home alone
movie everyone loved him he was on like
i'm pretty sure some rappers have had
him in music videos and songs a few
things yeah but like why was he only
racist the second he ran into office
that's something that i noticed as well
and tried to change things
i like that's why i think there's people
behind the scenes that just like that in
the media
yeah because that's weird if he was
racist it would the media loves
canceling people
so why didn't it come out before
i don't know i've had that thought like
i don't
when he wasn't in
office or trying to run for president
i never saw anything about him being
racist but as soon as he came in
for
what
what i may think when he came into
office
from what i saw it was like all the
undercover people that were
racist
or
were against
whomever
it like brought them to light and it
gave them gave them a voice in a sense
and that's something that i notice and
i don't know if that's why people
connect that to him or they just have
the thought that he's racist i'm not
sure but i just wish that
more the things that he did
were talked about because it
it was stuff that you never know like
when he was talking about um
the unemployment went down i was like
when did that happen when i first heard
that i was like huh that was you
remember the economy was booming before
the
uh before covet happened
yeah it was like record high wow
it was the
economy was doing real well before that
happened
and then it's kind of like
covet kind of seems a little isn't that
a little weird i've i've always thought
coveted was weird i was like hmm it kind
of turns out all of a sudden
right yeah right right before the next
election
and then the vaccine came out right
after the election mm-hmm
trust me and then black lives like the
black lives matter came in like that
that whole movement right before it's
just weird timing
trust me we go on and on all day about
coven i've had my thoughts about it and
yeah
this point 27 27 i gave you an extra 14.
but
black don't crack and i i know i know i
look really good i look really good
when you watch that moment
it must have just been like man i have
been screaming about this stuff here's
the guy doing this stuff and they dare
sit there but it's just one little
example they've been doing this for
years
obama's mom sent him back from indonesia
when he's 10 years old to eventually go
to punahou the finest prep school in the
state of hawaii because she wanted him
to have better education michelle obama
did not go to a charter school they
didn't exist then but she did not go to
her local government school because it
was so bad she got on the bus and went
to a much better school ice cube the
rapper
he didn't go to his local government
school he went to taft with the time
with predominantly white so what are
they telling you they're telling you
they want choice but you don't get
choice and they're beholden to the
teachers union that adamantly opposes
choice for all the reasons i just now
mentioned they don't get their automatic
dues from the teachers union and
therefore it threatens them they
couldn't care less about the quality of
education
and i mentioned the 300 000 teachers uh
in in
in
public school teachers in california and
the average year only 2.2 were fired
imagine
i told you between five and seven
percent of them are perceived to be
incompetent there are twenty thousand
cops here in in uh in l.a
imagine if five percent of them were bad
cops that's a thousand cops on the
streets we wouldn't put up with it we
put up with 15 000 bad teachers
who wants to do something about that we
do they don't but i'm the bad guy i'm
the uncle tom think about it open up
your eyes who's on your side now the
beauty of our of our private ballots is
you can go in there
and your mailing ballot and you can vote
for a republican and nobody has to know
about it so i'm telling these
independents and democrats pull the
lever for me don't tell anybody
don't touch it who's on your side
if you're looking for more honesty
yo
yo
what
that actually wasn't
the interview i thought it was but what
did you think
you know what pearl
i'm gonna i'm gonna need a new brain
after this this whole thing
it
it's it's good to see a black person
talk like this honestly because
it's a different view
and it
opens up
your view as a black person
to
to know that
maybe there aren't this many obstacles
in the way and maybe
maybe the stuff that my parents dealt
with or my grandparents dealt with
is
not as big
as it was to where
it's a force that i
i can't i can't progress like it's just
that wall that i can't progress past
maybe now now it's not a wall maybe a
little gate that i can crop climb over
and then progress
so i i liked it i don't know if that's
fat that i liked it but
you know
call me what you want i think the way i
want what do you know they'll love you
on my channel that one the other side
finds that they might not but that's
hopefully if the other side sees it
they'll be open hopefully their
minds will be open and
they'll have conversations well i think
it's good because people have these
conversations behind the scenes they're
just afraid to get on camera yes
yes are afraid to talk to
family and friends that think
differently and don't want to start an
argument
okay guys um